un po di tempo fa un un amico mi ha
chiesto se fosse interessato a
partecipare un evento ted che aveva come
come tema di base
l'interazione tra intelligenza
artificiale uomo ho colto con piacere
perché questo l'esatto tema nel settore
aeronautico è l'argomento base di
discussione negli ultimi dieci anni
in particolare nei dipartimenti che si
occupano di operazioni di volo e di
addestramento
poi lo stesso argomento è diventato
diventasse come spesso accade anche
famosa a tutti quando si verificano
sfortunati incidenti come ad esempio
l'ultimo il boeing 737 max di etiopia
oppure il l'airbus 330 di air france
sull'atlantico il boeing tribal server
di asian a san francisco
tutti questi eventi avevano come stretta
analogia l'utilizzo dell'automazione a
bordo dei velivoli moderni velivoli
moderni anno non ho visto un'evoluzione
molto veloce negli ultimi dieci anni e
sono passati per così dire da aeroplani
completamente analogici ad aeroplani
esclusivamente digitali e forse questa
questa evoluzione così veloce non è
andata di pari passo con la nostra
capacità nel prevedere quali potessero
essere le criticità che stavano dietro a
questo sviluppo per farvi capire meglio
che cosa significa intelligenza
artificiale oro meglio automazione
all'interno di un velivolo vi mostra
alcune immagini che sono in realtà un
confronto tra gli aeroplani tipici di
due epoche diverse non non così distanti
beh le differenze diciamo che sono sono
immediatamente visibili a parte il
design accattivante del
del velivolo di destra la differenza
sostanziale sta in quello che si vede
una moltitudine gli strumenti analogici
hanno lasciato il posto a da alcuni
display digitali
oltre a questo anche la cloche che era
al centro delle delle gambe del pilota
lasciato il posto a due joystick
beh adesso infatti il i comandi di volo
sono anche anche anche loro controllati
da un computer che su input del pilota
controlla l'aeroplano facendo uno zoom
su questi strumenti di volo vi racconto
qual è in realtà la sostanziale
differenza che c'è tra questa
strumentazione ed in realtà è la logica
che sta dietro l'interpretazione di
questi strumenti nella strumentazione di
sinistra aveva richiesto un grande
sforzo da parte del pilota per cercare
di capire come in questo caso quello che
rappresentano questi strumenti quale sia
la posizione dell'aereo plano rispetto
al terreno all'orografia circostante
quindi il pilota per ottenere il
risultato voluto doveva leggere
un'innumerevole quantità di strumenti
analogici e processarli all'interno del
proprio cervello per il risultato che
desideravo ottenere adesso invece questo
stesso risultato è fornito
immediatamente dal software che gli dà
direttamente l'immagine di ciò che sta
accadendo è quindi molto più facile
scarica il pilota da un enorme lavoro
tutta la strumentazione di bordo ha la
stessa logica di di comprensione di
lavoro questo ad esempio è di sinistra e
l'impianto elettrico di un aeroplano e
uno dei pannelli che sta sopra alla
testa nella vera il panel sopra la testa
del pilota
la differenza sta sostanzialmente nel
fatto che il pannello di sinistra
richiedesse una conoscenza profonda di
che cosa era l'impianto elettrico di un
aeroplano adesso in realtà il computer
ci offre direttamente lo status le
eventuali avarie le anomalie
direttamente in un'immagine che
è direttamente comprensibile quest'altro
è un altro strumento che permette al
pilota di capire la posizione del
proprio aree plana rispetto agli altri
software infatti del degli aeroplani
moderni dialogano tra di loro
questo ci permette di eventualmente
poter creare una manovra di scampo nel
caso in cui controllori di volo che sono
ancora i gestori del traffico aereo
prendano una baia facciano un errore
allo stesso modo le tecnologie che
utilizziamo bordo degli aeroplani sono
le stesse che utilizzano chi li progetta
quindi qui gli ingegneri ad esempio di
da so che un'azienda francese leader
nella progettazione dei business jet
moderni con la realtà virtuale sono in
grado di calarsi direttamente dentro ciò
che stanno progettando ed è quindi un
passo un passo enorme nella costruzione
degli aeroplani e l'automazione al
giorno d'oggi ha raggiunto un livello di
sofisticazione tale per cui al
pilotaggio manuale relegato solamente la
primissima fase del del volo per così
dire dal decollo alla detrazione del
carrello da quel momento in poi
l'autopilota si prende carico della
guida della condotta del del volo fino
all'atterraggio compreso l'atterraggio e
il decollo rimane ancora una una fase
per cui la peculiarità delle avarie che
possono succedere in quella fase
richiedono ancora l'intervento manuale
da parte del pilota
in questo video brevissimo vi mostro la
fase finale di una cava joe condotto
completamente in maniera automatica in
una condizione di massima visibilità
buon libro inizia
a trenta metri dal suolo e piloti
vedranno la pista a 10 metri 23 secondi
prima della toccata tengono le mani sui
comandi esclusivamente per una questione
di reattività nel caso il software
abbiamo malfunzionamento ma in realtà il
pilota l'autopilota conduce il
l'atterraggio alla frenata in maniera
completamente automatica appena
sentirete un suono sarà quella la fase
in cui l'autopilota vi darà ai comandi
al pilota che a bassa velocità sarà in
grado di portare la re plano al
parcheggio in modo sicuro
la tecnologia disponibile è già in grado
di metterci a disposizione mezzi a
completa guida autonoma i mezzi a
conduzione autonomo sono già presenti
sul mercato e non sono ancora stati
introdotti ma l'ago della bilancia nel
fatto della riuscita veloce ed efficace
di questi mezzi in realtà rimane ancora
il consumatore il passeggero la propria
disponibilità la disponibilità del
passeggero a salire su un mezzo dove
affida la propria vita completamente al
computer ricordiamoci anche ancora il
backup principale in un aereo alle
eventuali avarie del computer e ancora
il pilota cosa che qui mancherebbe
completamente andiamo ad analizzare un
po quelli che sono emersi come vantaggi
e svantaggi dell'automazione che è stata
introdotta nella nell'aviazione partiamo
dai dagli svantaggi sono
fondamentalmente tre
la prima è la perdita di percezione di
ciò che sta accadendo
infatti gli errori del software sono
spesso subdoli e si celano dietro a un
sistema i computer che per noi per
l'uomo per il pilota impenetrabile e
quando questi errori si manifestano sono
di difficile percezione questo questo
stesso accadimento è successo ad esempio
ai piloti dell'airbus 330 di air france
era in volo tra il brasile e parigi nel
2009 ea un certo punto dopo diverse ore
di volo hanno visto il manifestarsi di
una serie innumerevole di incongruenze a
varie
beh pur avendo grandi esperienze non
sono stati in grado di capire che cosa
stesse funzionando bene quali invece
strumenti stessa da danno informazioni
arrone fino a che non ne hanno perso
completamente il controllo
l'inconveniente più automatico al al non
al non fare qualcosa credo che sia la
perdita delle abilità in questo caso la
perdita di abilità al volo manuale
tenete presente che un pilota
conduce manualmente l'aeroplano tra i
tre ei sei minuti rispetto all'intera
durata del volo di magari 10 ore
e allo stesso modo anche le aziende che
addestrano i piloti hanno focalizzato
quasi esclusivamente l'addestramento per
far diventare il pilota un bravo
operatore di sistema perché questo siamo
in fondo però relegando alla parte del
volo manuale una piccola parte
dell'addestramento questo è la causa che
ha scaturito fondamentalmente un
incidente di circa 7 8 anni fa al boeing
tribal severin di asiana e tre piloti
tre comandanti di grande esperienza
stavano conducendo un avvicinamento
manuale l'aver porto di san francisco e
che è un un tipo di avvicinamento che un
pilota le prime armi e non su un aereo
da turismo conduce normalmente senza
nessun inconveniente boe hanno imac
condotto l'avvicinamento il modo in modo
disastroso per mancanza di abilità per
mancanza di praticità nel condurre
questo tipo di avvicinamento l'ultima
criticità emerse ultimamente con
l'incidente del boeing 737 max di
etiopia che riguarda l'invadenza di
quanto il il software negli aeroplani
moderni possa prevalere sul tentativo
dei comandi del pilota
questo è un tema ancora aperto e al
momento irrisolto infatti il 737 max e
il suo software che lo controlla non è
ancora entrato in servizio e il tema di
discussione è principalmente questo di
quanto l'automazione possa prevalere
sulla volontà dell'uomo nel in questo
caso del del pilota
grazie a dio i pro invece sono molto
maggiori rispetto a quelli che sono
contro il conto del dell'automazione
nella
l'aviazione e partiamo da quelli forse
meno importanti magari per noi ma lo
sono invece per le compagnie aeree sono
quelli economici
infatti la strumentazione digitale costa
molto meno rispetto a quella analogica e
allo stesso modo l'addestramento anche
dei piloti è molto più veloce e
soprattutto è valida su diversi tipi di
aeroplani che condividono lo stesso
tipologia di jonica per ultimo l'aspetto
più importante la sicurezza si è
decisamente elevata dall'avvento di
un'automazione massiva e la ragione
fondamentalmente una e l'uomo è ancora
la causa numero uno di incidenti nel
mondo renatico
e invece il software ha una grande
peculiarità a fronte di un errore
commesso può essere riprogrammato e non
commetterà mai la seconda volta lo
stesso errore
cosa che non è una caratteristica
dell'uomo vado verso la conclusione
facendo alcune considerazioni e il
digitale queste sono un po più
trasversali credo in diversi settori
dell'industria e non solo nella
nell'automazione relativa all'aviazione
il digitale non è solamente uno
strumento ma è un profondo cambiamento
culturale e probabilmente le risposte
che stanno dietro a come questo
cambiamento debba essere introdotto
probabilmente non sono di natura
tecnologica
cinque giorni fa la ceo di ibm a milano
ha fatto un'interessante affermazione e
ibm per il suo futuro non cerca
personale con conoscenze specifiche ma
bensì personale che abbia voglia di
apprendere la ragione sta nel fatto che
anche soprattutto l'istruzione è
profondamente ha subito lo stesso
profondo cambiamento
di tutto il resto
una volta la distruzione era era fatta
da due periodi un periodo un lungo
periodo di apprendimento seguito da un
periodo di nel quale si metteva in
pratica oggi questi due periodi corrono
parallelamente come fossero in un unico
flusso
l'ultima considerazione in realtà una
domanda che a mio parere è interessante
continuare a porsi con l'evoluzione
della tecnologia dell'automazione in
questo caso ed è appunto che cosa sia
saggio portare con noi attraverso lo
sviluppo dell'automazione
dobbiamo cercare di capire soprattutto
in un settore dove la sicurezza è molto
importante che cosa quali delle
conoscenze che attualmente abbiamo e di
cui siamo assolutamente padroni e quali
delle abilità che abbiamo sia saggio
portare con noi perché questa evoluzione
sia il più sicura ed efficace possibile
vi lascio con una frase che è una
interessante definizione di tecnologia
ed è di uno scrittore canadese william
gibson che dice che la tecnologia è
moralmente neutrale fino a qui e non la
applichiamo e credo che questo sia
abbastanza calzante con con il via nel
settore di cui mi occupo ho concluso e
vi ringrazio spero di non avervi
annoiato con con il mio argomento grazie
mille